so i always prefer to do something than
not to doing something so whenever
even when i walk wake up in the morning
i want to go
jogging or not and i i'm tired i'm not
going to talk today and but i remember
that whenever i'm doing something
when i do something i never regret
[Music]
thank you for joining me on 20
milliliters how are you today
good good nice to meet you we have
thank you we have we have a lot to cover
uh but before we cover
all the mileage we have for this
interview we have to talk about your
bike journeys uh you know you started
you by mentioning to me that you
traveled with your wife with tents on
the bikes
all across europe and you even traveled
with the whole family on a
non-competitive cycling event through
iowa right
yeah yeah bike is me i'm the bike so
also in also in the silicon valley i
used to
to bike every day to walk and back and
here in united in israel now i'm in
israel
also we are we are on television because
the television you can cycle also
everywhere so i try to avoid my
my my car and also it's good because my
son
is very he likes uh he he try his pro
he protesting against all the climate
change
so i'm very proud to uh that
that my son can be proud of me that i'm
using bike whatever i can
and yeah and as student i cycle with my
wife for two months
in in europe with bike and again then
another trip in that was in scandinavia
then another time in
in in scotland and then in the united
states also i cycled
a lot and including with my family one
week we crossed iowa from one side to
the other there is a
it's a big event called ragbrai um
and that was very very constantly in awe
the people that i'm speaking to like
yourself you're so busy and you and
you're so successful in your domain yet
you have these incredible passions and
adventures
and you don't do them lightly you go all
the way you you travel 2
000 miles with your wife with tents or
you travel all across iowa with your
family
i'm gaining inspiration for myself but i
have to go to
to the main event and to the main
mileage you're a researcher at samsung
you're an expert in computer vision and
augmented reality
and i'm especially excited for this
episode because i'm excited to talk
about
what is augmented reality and where are
we heading especially in the context of
your work so the tan
maybe can you take me back a little bit
about your journey
into this computer vision space and and
then tell me a little bit about where we
are
okay so personally my background has
more computer vision
and also a bit of computer graphics and
and for me augmented reality virtual
reality we can discuss it but that's
what i like it it's about the
integration so you take computer
graphics and compute the vision and
and and and integrate them and have
something
uh that you you see and and for me also
that's also something that
for me is very important is is is the
feedback
so for me as a developer that i develop
something and i get the feedback i don't
need
someone to tell me if it's better or not
i see if it's
it's better i see the reality in front
of the user like
it's not only a better algorithm that
runs faster and someone say oh
now it's faster more efficient i what i
like is just the
the interaction with the computer with
the screen
and if it's augmented reality virtual
reality it's not
only the screen it could be also glasses
and
and what drives you into computer vision
starting out
why why going i get to watch him what
drew what
computer vision again that's because i
because because of visual
aspect so because i see what's what i
get and
and and and understand the world and uh
and how computer and how the computer
can understand the world and how
computer can uh can
learn and it's got just no i started
20 years ago even more 25 years ago and
it was
not so many cameras now everything is
cameras every phone has camera amazing
camera so
the potential of computer vision just
grew and grew and
understanding of of of the image is much
much better
and and again the instant direction
having been being able to to
to to see what you're doing and that's
what
i like the most and what's also very
interesting is no
because for us the human it's it's you
see something it's it's so obvious what
you see and but to teach computer to
understand what you see
it's it's a big challenge um
and that's part of
now when we are for augmented reality
ask about
you have two parts one is understanding
of the world because you have to
to visualize so maybe i'll just give a
few words about what is augmented
reality is
also there are several terms compute
there's virtual reality where you see
only
the virtual only the graphics you don't
see the the actual world you just see
everything is graphics and there's
augmented reality or mixed reality there
are some differences between all that
but
but in general let's call it augmented
reality that's
you have the world but on top of the
world you have some object that you add
some information to the world it could
be
uh through the screen of of the of the
phone
like that on the phone you see the world
with a camera and also add some
information so
um google has a lot of uh
very good code tool code that
gives you a lot of information you can
use it and it just gets better and
better because you understand the world
you can understand plans you can
understand what the
um where everything is located uh
personally i
i prefer as a developer to work with the
glasses
in glasses like hololens microsoft and
those other
uh magiclip and other companies that's
for me
that's the magic because then you really
see the world and then you also
put again you put the graphics on top of
that
yeah but extra layer but that's even
more challenging because
you really have to understand the scene
you really have to understand
not only the scene and where to put
something but you have to also
track the the head motions you have to
to understand how how the head moves
because then you can really know how to
render
how to locate the object in the right
thing and and if you don't do it right
it looks
it looks wrong so it's very we are
assuming again
it's very sensitive to that and um
it's very difficult to trick us uh
and and you know every everything it
also it has to walk
very efficiently in real time because
you cannot have any
latency that's another challenge with
with augmented reality the the
speed should be very very processing
speed should be that everything has to
be very efficient
and like that every jittering every in
virtual reality you can cheat in
augmented reality you cannot really
cheat because you see again you can see
the
road and and where it is now
i think most of computers many many
companies big companies
they try and do something and
for many years now it's it's it's
considered as something that is the next
the next thing but it's still promising
more promising than then you know you
have also
also facebook and and then google
and and i know some robots about apple
and but no one really makes money of
that so it's still
potential because
because whenever when you have it and
once
and they call it sometimes they call it
like a superman once you have
disabilities when you
once you get even if you don't like it
that's
again that's the claim that in the
future even if someone doesn't like it
if for example i see you and i get some
information that you cannot
know about me i have some advantage of
top of you
so i don't really like the approach but
in general that's that's
reality so if i have something that with
augmented reality you
get more information than someone
without it and so one day maybe you
you'll not so you you'll have if you
want to be
in and know everything you'll need
wherever you like it or not
um so i i would love to i would love to
spend the last five minutes or so
talking about where we're headed because
i am terribly excited
and frightened of how of how our world
is going to look
in a few dozen years uh both in terms of
you know people that are aging
and loneliness especially with cobit i
mean it's it's very
it's become very apparent how necessary
this technology is
but before that i would i would still
love to to understand a little bit
better
what is essentially augmented reality
today so
are people really actively working on
this is this mainstream and i'm drawing
a parallel to
autonomous vehicles i had a great chat
with a product manager at one of the
leading autonomous vehicles company on
this show
and one of the things that she mentioned
was that you know we we had a big surge
of technology
we've advanced a lot and we've reached
this like 95 96
threshold and now we're realizing that
the last five percent
is incredibly harder than we thought and
so we're almost there but we have such a
big way to go because that's
that's the big threshold is that the
same thing with augmented reality
i think yes and no so i think it it is
yes because if you want something
perfect there's
still a lot of things to do to make it
work
i think there's the problem with
augmented reality is the awkwardness so
there's no
no killer applications so still why
would people like google and google
when they have the google glasses so
right yes you get more information but
you look awkward so if there's not
enough
extra information people so still people
waiting for this killer application that
is not there yet maybe
you know just games but not it's not
enough to just have
games and entertainment um
so i but but still there's a lot of
uh that the technology is really it's
it's getting it getting it's getting
there so it's not too far for something
that you can
use but expensive so the
glasses like hololens mediclip that's
that's that's something that costs
two three thousand dollar a piece that's
too much for consumers so
that's something that that that has to
be solved before people can use it
because with the
expensive ones you have very good
results very very good
but if you want something that is much
cheaper 10 times cheaper then
tracking is not good enough and so but
that's you know
the hardware when hardware is getting
better cheaper cameras getting
cheaper then yeah it's it's i think
technology of course there's more
to do improve but i think we're in the
right way and i get the killer
application why would people do it
you know in the future they're talking
about also lenses instead of glasses
it's very creepy uh
i don't know but i think yeah
i believe that that's something if again
like even even if you like it or not
i think it's gonna happen you have to
use it it's going to happen
yeah because i'm asking this very er
very honestly because
we had such a big hype and everybody was
talking about and you had magic leap
that was in stealth mode for so long
raising so much money and then all of a
sudden you stop really hearing about
these advancements
you do have oculus and hololens and
those but but you don't really see
me and my friends talking about these
technologies
as much as we did even five years ago
which is counter-intuitive because i
would expect that now we'd be talking
about it much more than before
i remember going to conferences and the
person with the google glass was the
most popular person in the room
so so what i'm hearing from you is that
there i can be optimistic
and i should be planning for a nearby
future
when it will be less awkward and more
and more beneficial to take part in this
new humanity
yes i i think that's that's their
directions and
because again there's so much things you
can learn and do with that and
so much extra information you can get so
i think
sooner or later maybe later but it's
going to happen and again there's also
the prices that's going to to drop and
and i think so many big players out
there so
and like you said that it was very big
hype and
some small companies were closed because
it's it's difficult to
drive some air right but the big big
companies are still there and i think
it's going to happen
maybe not as soon as they thought but
so so now it's the part that i'm that
i'm most excited about
where are we heading so let's talk let's
say 10 years down the line or 20 years
down the line
what what do you envision our world
will look like with augmented reality as
part of our society
in in a modest expectation given the
technology that you're expecting to grow
how do you envision humanity operating
or at least places like you know tel
aviv silicon valley new york
okay so maybe we have to so separate
between what i want and
maybe what i think that's going to
happen because i want to hear that i
like
yes i like the technology first of all i
made a duality like i said
before from that technology side for my
as a developer for because
yeah but but not but i'm not sure that
as a user i really like it
so i i i because if if i just
try to imagine all these creepy
situations i'm not sure so i'm not sure
i really like to
have it in the future it's also scary
for me uh
but but um but but if we
just mention this a corona thing so we
uh you know
sometimes you far from the former family
being able to
uh so that's the good thing so i don't
so that's the thing that i really think
that
are beneficial so you want to have now
everything is virtual we are in zoom
right now but i want to make a meeting
with you and we want to discuss
something right here is on the table
and with the air glasses we can discuss
it
again there's this it's already possible
with some
uh with more advanced uh headsets that
are more too expensive like i mentioned
earlier but
now you can already look at the same
object and and
look at that around it so i think for
for for high-tech for many other for
professional
use there's a lot of things that you can
share and and
and and be able to to gain a lot of and
save like
like zoom you don't have to meet to do
it you can do it from home
and like you also mentioned for the for
the elderly people
and maybe they cannot treat they cannot
treat it's too small but
now you can assume that you do that in
the ui
um simple enough and intuitive enough
that's
that's also a challenge because you know
we know whether it was computer we
use the mouse and the keyboard we're
already used to it but with augmented
duality
how to use so there's a lot of
challenges there that your ipad so you
know the
technology they have to head track and
hand tracking and head tracking
eyes checking none of this that was very
useful so
or not it works but it's not so
something if you want to change you do
something like that to change the screen
or or do something like that or some
science that are not very intuitive uh
if we solve that
so if i i just mentioned that because we
think about old
old people so how if you make it
intuitive enough
and maybe hopefully we'll find a way to
interact with that
so family that want to meet each other
and
know together with the holograms or
things like that you can really feel
like
so every time you use augmented reality
even more
virtual reality sometimes i use it and
then when i when i'm done
i just take my glass off and oh whoa i'm
i'm
i mean you i'm i'm back to real life so
i'm back to the boring world yeah
it's so easy to forget about your
environment when you're especially with
virtual reality and that's something
that's i think that's
if we find again like some applications
that something that can do a lot of good
so
no i'm i'm a i'm terribly excited about
the about the prospect of being able to
talk with my with my grandparents
uh from afar due to covet i can't miss i
can't go inside their house and visit
them
and and it kills me inside that that and
i'm saying like why do we
why do i need to use you know video
conferencing on shabbat dinner
to to to wish them shabbat shalom i want
to be able to be in the same room with
them because
it's because it feels to me that you
know we all we're almost there and
and it's so relevant today and it's
going to continue being so relevant
moving forward and so i'm i'm incredibly
excited about this technology
are you and one more thing it's about
the haptic there's a haptic as a
hepatic feedback that's something that's
is still missing and that's more
expensive
that's so that's part that is a bit
behind
because you also want to touch you want
to hug your grandparents so if you could
hack them or something feel that and
there there's some
some controllers that just vibrate a bit
but it's not much
more than that and the better ones are
very expensive than right
that's something that has to maybe thin
like you might ask him for 10 20 minutes
i
i use i hope that this one will
get much much better because that will
make a lot of difference
all right i just read an interesting
review of the new playstation
game console which the playstation 5
introduces haptic
feedback through the remote controllers
so that you're more
immersed into the game and one of the
things that they said and i read a few
of the gamers
gamers designers um decision making
process they said that they
intentionally
minimized the use of this new feature
because they were afraid that humans
will not be receptive to it yet
it'll be too much for them so i'm
especially curious given what we
talked here about how we as humanity are
going to accept this new reality
and just like you mentioned that you
take off those glasses and you're back
into the
the the boring world or the default
world whatever every person will
experience it differently
i think that's fascinating the time i
want to really thank you for for being
so generous with your time
i wanted to talk about j ventures and
and and some of the work that we do
there but we don't have time for that
but i'd love to
uh get from you three words that you
would use to describe yourself
so one is maybe active so i always
prefer to do something than not to doing
something so whenever
even when i walk wake up in the morning
i want to go
jogging or not then i i'm tired i'm not
going to talk today and but i remember
that whenever i'm doing something
when i do something i never regret so
even if i'm alright
it's it's i'm more i regret more times
about things i didn't do than
about something that i want to do so
whenever i have to think about should i
do it or not it's up
my approach is yes do it even if i like
like a startup
just do it i love it um that's that's
one thing
and the other thing is just no i think
i'm very calm so
it's very difficult for me to to someone
to make me
angry or i'm
i have my it's very my very very
difficult to make me mad maybe that's
why i'm not i don't have
so much startups because i i like i'm
i'm
i'm calm you seem very fulfilled and
calm
and i'm taking a lot of inspiration from
that from that first
uh that first word being active and not
regretting
even when you're even when your
intuition says maybe this isn't right
but then you rationalize and say well
i'm more often than not i don't regret
i'm enjoying the experience
and so i think that's really wonderful
wonderful thank you very very much
thank you for being on the show thank
you for being so generous with your time
and i'll see you around the j ventures
meetings
yeah see you bye-bye
you